(upbeat music)
- I see color as a form of communication.
I feel like it tells a story.
When I look at colors like in a painting,
I think automatically,
can I put that on a head?
(upbeat music)
My name is Daniel Moon,
and I'm a hair colorist.
I first started getting into hair
when I was in the Marine Corps.
I barbered myself and other friends.
I was granted permission to exit
the Marine Corps to go to hair school.
Being so restricted in the military,
I think getting out of
it, there were no limits.
Restriction was enforced on me,
so when it came to creating,
I had a vow that I'd never restrict myself
from doing something that
I felt like I wanted to
and somehow came up with this magic
way of coloring hair.
So freehand hair coloring is looking
at the head as a canvas.
Whether it's short hair or long hair,
being able to just paint on it
as if it was a sculpture.
I find inspiration everywhere.
I look to the art world;
I look to the magazine
world; I look in books;
I look where people don't
think about looking.
When I'm choosing colors and designs
I imagine like a checkerboard.
This purple is here, this red is here.
Can I connect this color to that color?
I'm looking at it from every angle.
Top, bottom, left, right,
and then just playing with those
different kind of shapes.
I don't think about being different
from other hair stylists.
I create work that is different for me;
it's different from my last piece.
(calm music)
I think people dye their hair to have fun-
to create a persona that's fun to live in.
Did some big color changes
and had some great
collaborations with Madonna,
Katy Perry, Nicole
Richie, and Zoe Kravitz.
The work that I create is temporary,
and that is a romantic thing.
Because it fades away, hair grows out,
I can spend three hours,
six hours on a piece,
and then it could walk out the door,
and then it's never seen again.
I like that it's an art
form that washes away.
I'd like to just continue on creating
and just making something that
I've never seen before.
(upbeat music)